If you're familiar with the Windows
control panel, then you're going to also
be familiar with the functionality of
the Mac OS system preferences. The
system preferences is a one-stop shop
for configuration settings for your
operating system. So, if you find
yourself needing to modify the way that
the keyboard is operating, the way the
display works, or how you access the
network, you'll find all of those
options and much more inside of system
preferences.
The display preferences in Mac OS give
us control over what is shown on the
different monitors connected to our
system. You can set these up to be
monitors that are side by side or you
can arrange them to be in almost any
configuration you'd like. You can also
change where the menus are located in
Mac OS so that if you don't like them on
your main screen, you can move them to a
secondary display. And from here, you
can modify the resolution used by your
displays. You can change the brightness
values or if you want to get into
detailed color grading of each monitor,
you can do that from within the displays
option. The network settings available
in Mac OS are very similar to the
network settings that you would find in
almost any operating system. You can
modify network configurations for wired
or wireless connections and you can
define IPv4 addressing and IPv6
addressing. You can choose to manually
set those settings yourself or you can
choose to obtain a DHCP address. And of
course, you can get into detailed
network configurations of things like
your DNS settings, 802.1x
authentication, and other detailed
configurations. For example, the
detailed breakdown of this Ethernet
adapter allows us to modify the TCP IP
configuration settings. We can update
DNS, the Windows internet naming system,
802.1x authentication, specific
configurations for potential proxies you
might be using, and modification of the
hardware settings of the network
interface
card. Most organizations will have a
number of different printers that are
connected to the network, and you can
identify and modify configuration
settings for any of these printers from
the printers and scanners option. If you
have printers directly connected to your
Mac OS system, you can share those
printers with other people on the
network or modify the permissions
associated with each printer. You can
also drill down into a printer to find
out more information about what may be
in the printer queue, what type of
options or supplies might be required
for this printer, and you may be able to
view toner levels or ink levels for this
printer.
Mac OS also includes options for privacy
and security, so you can determine what
information on your machine might be
able to be shared with other folks. From
here, you can allow or disallow access
to different types of data such as
location services, the files and folders
on your system, anything that you might
have in a media or Apple Music folder,
and other categories as well. If you use
Mac OS, you may have seen this pop up
while you're installing or running new
applications. For example, if you've
recently installed any online
conferencing software and you start that
software, it might ask if this software
is allowed to use your microphone and
your camera. That means you get to
decide whether each individual
application will have access to
information that could be sensitive or
private. And if you've disabled access
for an application, the application
simply will not have access to that
data. This means that you can configure
your operating system to have the right
level of privacy for you. For example,
you might want to set what applications
can access your photos and what
applications are not allowed access to
your photos. If we click the photos
section, you can then go through each
individual application and decide
whether that app should have access to
that resource or you can disable access.
The accessibility category can change
the way the operating system presents
information to you. So you can modify
from a vision perspective what
information is shown on the screen. You
can change the information that you're
hearing and how you're hearing that in
the operating system and make the OS
itself something that's easier to use
for you. This also allows you to enable
certain applications to have additional
access to things like keyboard, mouse,
audio, and video resources. Some
thirdparty accessibility apps will need
additional access to some of the
hardware of your computer in order to
make that hardware easier to use. You'll
need to enable that access inside of the
accessibility option. This might also
serve as a security feature. This
prevents any thirdparty applications
from gaining access to things like your
keyboard without you specifically giving
it that permission. Each one of these
different categories under accessibility
has a different number of options. For
example, if we click the zoom option,
all of the options within that area will
be specific to zooming into or out of
information on your screen. You can
change keyboard shortcuts, use the
trackpad gesture to zoom. You can enable
or disable the scroll gesture using
modifier keys, or you can use a modifier
key for scroll gesture. For example, on
my Mac OS, the control modifier key
allows me to hold down the control
button and use my scroll wheel to be
able to zoom in and out of information
that's on my
display. In a previous video, we talked
about Apple's backup capabilities. And
if you want to modify anything relating
to the time machine application, you can
also do that within your system
preferences. This allows you to add or
remove different storage drives for time
machine. And these may be directly
connected storage drives or you may be
connecting to this time machine volume
across the network. Once this is set up,
it will begin performing backups
automatically every hour. and you'll be
able to go back in time to the last 24
hours and look at different versions of
the same file that may have been stored
on your system. Once you get past 24
hours, Time Machine creates automatic
daily backups for the entire month. And
then there are weekly backups done for
all previous months. Time Machine will
continue to back up all of this data
every hour. And when it begins to run
out of room, it will start deleting the
oldest information so that it can
continue to make these backups as time
goes on.